we start things off tonight however with
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Herridge on what clearly looks
like a planned terror attack in Canada
even Catherine well thank you bread
tonight Canadian officials are calling
it a major and complex investigation
after a white rental van mowed down
pedestrians during the lunch hour
leaving at least nine dead and another
16 injured many at a level one trauma
center police service has mobilized all
available resources and I can assure the
public all our available resources have
been brought in to address this tragic
situation and to investigate this
situation at approximately 1:30 Eastern
the emergency calls started coming in
that a van going about 40 miles an hour
jumped the curb ramming pedestrians and
anything else in its way passers-by
stopped on the spot doing CPR on victims
the dead were covered with blankets
witnesses described the incident as
deliberate with the vehicle traveling
about a half mile along a major artery
that runs north-south through the city
of Toronto
after the van stopped near another major
intersection the suspect got out of the
vehicle brandishing a black object
witnesses reported the suspect claimed
to have a weapon before the police
takedown Canadian authorities have not
identified the suspect whether he acted
alone was part of a larger group and no
word yet on the motive the terror group
Isis has called on its followers to use
vehicles as weapons and they did so with
deadly effect in Nice France two years
ago killing 87 people if confirmed as
terrorism the Toronto attack would be
one of the worst on North American soil
it's a nightmare I got two young and
Empress and I seen a lady with her leg
and oh man gruesome scenes is really bad
out there I couldn't believe what I seen
man oh man everybody how these people on
the streets kidding one by one
Toronto law enforcement is now working
closely with Canadian federal officials
Canada's Minister for Public Safety the
equivalent of the Homeland Security
Secretary said there is no link between
the incident and a g7 meeting also in
Toronto at this point Brett Catherine
thank you will follow for some updates
if we get them